Bonjour à tous. Aujourd'hui nous sommes avec
Paul qui a une start up qui s'appelle Eugène.
Paul peux-tu nous en parler parce
que vraiment c'est top.
Bien sûr. Eugène est un lecteur de code barre que l'on vient fixer à
proximité de sa poubelle de cuisine
pour bien trier, mieux consommer et
faire ses courses. Le concept est très
simple : on va scanner le
code barre de son emballage avant de le
jeter et Eugène va vous indiquer la bonne
consigne de tri.
Consigne de tri qui est géolocalisée et
détaillée. Elle peuvent
varier d'une ville à l'autre.
Donc ça marche
directement avec le code barre du produit ?
Oui.
Vous avez des partenariats ?
Le principe c'est également de venir
récompenser l'utilisateur pour son
geste de tri. A chaque fois que vous
scannez un emballage vous allez gagner
des points
qui pourront être convertis en bons
de réduction ou bons d'achat chez un
certain nombre de partenaires.
Chaque produit scanné est
enregistré dans votre historique de
consommation. Cela vous permet
d'analyser et de suivre votre
consommation au jour le jour.
De trouver des produits qui vous
correspondent en fonction de vos
critères environnementaux, des
allergènes, des ingrédients ...
Si je mange trop sucré je pourrais le savoir ?
Exactement. Combien de litres de coca j'ai bu le mois dernier ... Ca permet de
savoir aussi quels sont les produits qui contiennent du
gluten ou de l'huile de palme par exemple
dans mon alimentation. Comme un produit jeté est
souvent
un produit que l'on a besoin de racheter,
l'application vous permet de créer vos
listes de course.
Vous pouvez l'utiliser soit en magasin
comme une check list pour ne rien
oublier. Soit l'envoyer
directement dans le panier en ligne votre distributeur.
Donc ça
permet d'acheter en ligne, de mieux trier ?
Oui exactement.
De mieux consommer parce
que l'on a un vrai retour sur son historique.
Et tu me parlais également d'une
gamification où l'utilisateur gagne des points,
des remises, des bons d'achat ?
Exactement. Il y a deux freins au développement
du tri sélectif c'est
le manque d'informations sur le
recyclage et le manque d'incitation
concrète à faire le bon geste.
Avec Eugène le principe est
de récompenser l'utilisateur avec des points qu'il va transformer en bons d'achat, en
récompense. Il peut même faire un don à
une association s'il le souhaite.
Ok.
Pour l'inciter à faire cette démarche.
Quelle est l'idée de départ ? C'est un constat ?
Vous vous êtes rendu compte qu'il n'y avait pas d'outil qui permettait de trier correctement ?
Oui. L'ensemble des français
se disent favorables au tri.
Tout le monde reconnait que trier c'est bien
c'est le premier geste environnemental des français
et pourtant dans la pratique
il n'y en a seulement qu'un sur quatre qui le fait
correctement au quotidien.
D'accord.
Il y a beaucoup d'erreurs qui coûtent très cher
aux collectivités locales.
Les consommateurs sont
de plus en plus exigeants. Ils attendent
des marques et distributeurs un meilleur
accompagnement pour une démarche plus
citoyenne et plus responsable.
On parle beaucoup de consommer local, du bio.
C'est important, c'est un enjeu pour l'avenir.
L'idée c'est réunir ces différentes fonctionnalités dans un produit.
Depuis combien de temps travaillez-vous sur Eugène ?
On a créé Eugène en mai 2014. Cela fait 3 ans que nous développons le produit.
On développe des partenariats et aujourd'hui nous sommes prêts à le commercialiser.
Il est disponible en précommande sur notre site Internet.
Le lien est disponible dans la description.
A 79 euros
et la livraison est garantie sous 30 jours.
Quand sera t'il disponible ?
On peut déjà le précommander et
la livraison est prévue pour début
octobre
Lorsque l'on regarde un produit comme celui là
qui est un produit grande distribution.
Les informations de recyclage
ne sont pas claires. Je ne
comprends pas ce qu'il faut faire.
C'est le problème. C'est
rarement écrit sur le packaging et lorsque
c'est écrit c'est une consigne de tri
nationale alors que les consignes de tri
varient d'une ville à l'autre, d'un arrondissement à l'autre.
En digitalisant les consignes de tri on peut l'adapter à l'endroit où l'on vit.
Eugène est disponible
via une application
que l'on peut utiliser. Sur
l'AppStore et sur GooglePlay donc
Android et iOS.
Facile à utiliser ?
Oui. Nous avons une belle notice qui
vous explique bien le
fonctionnement.
Et qui est labellisé French Tech.
Je te remercie pour toutes ces
informations. Je souhaite bon courage
parce que vraiment c'est un produit qui
est à la fois écologique, qui permet de
faire du tri correctement.
Qui permet également d'avoir une
liste d'achats pour faire ses courses, de
commander en ligne. Il y a de la gamification. Il n'y a
que des avantages. C'est un
produit qu'il faut
posséder assez rapidement pour trier correctement
et puis ça vous solutionnera votre quotidien.
Merci beaucoup. Dites-moi ce que vous en pensez en commentaires.
Est-ce que vous faites du tri ?
Est ce que vous pensez le faire correctement ?
Est-ce qu'un produit comme celui-là vous paraît intéressant ?
Répondez-moi en commentaire et
je regarderai cela plus en détails.
Merci beaucoup à bientôt.
Merci aurevoir.